[Music]
why does Marvel hate epileptics typical
of Victor Von Doom to build a 30-foot
statue of himself
villainy villain does villainy things
also Victor Von Doom
why not villain von bad guy in the third
is it normal for welders to blowtorch
sparks everywhere while people walk
around with absolutely no security
fences scaffolding or normal
construction warning signs it's not a
real presentation in movies unless you
can display it with a 3d hologram
graphic that fills up nearly the whole
room as if his giveaway name wasn't
enough were introduced to Von Doom while
he sits in the dark in what is obviously
an evil chair same old read always
stretching reaching for the stars
haha Reed Richards is gonna be stretchy
soon remember that time you fucked up
here's the magazine about it in case you
don't come Wendy let us try and jump the
hilly brush holy Sh it's nip-tucked
Julian McMahon with the shield's Michael
Chiklis here we've got the entire FX
lineup from 2005 in this movie sudden
Jessica Alba also Wow all but one of the
five main characters is in this room I'm
really three minutes in I think you both
know my director of genetic research
Susan storm I sure do
thanks for reminding me of her name
storm doom it's like Marvel names its
characters be a mad lib also I know I'm
far from the first to point out like
this but I still have to give us in for
the fact that of the three characters
whose full names we've learned all have
names whose first and last portions
begin with the same letter that's not
anywhere near as cute as they think it
is what's the worst that can happen
what's the worst that could happen
cliche it's always right he's obviously
not always right if he's no longer
dating Jessica Alba what are we leaving
been asked when they're leaving on the
mission that only just got greenlit five
floors ago I'll be scheduling a lot Sue
Storm is the director of kinetic
research for this company but also
scheduled space launches for some reason
remember my brother Johnny
rock music plays between the first
mention of a character and his first
appearance in the next scene to signify
that he's a badass and doesn't follow
the rules
where did the car go why was the woman
he was kissing in that car driving down
this road to the launch site also what
brought Ben and Reed out here with
binoculars anyway were they like hey
let's go out to the deck and look for
Johnny when he drives up we'll be able
to figure out everything we need to know
about his character from here that
wingnut washed out of NASA for sneaking
to Victoria's Secret wannabes into a
flight simulator it sounds to me like he
didn't wash out a NASA but one NASA look
on your hard-ass former CEOs base if he
says bracelets I'm gonna be really upset
goddamn it
Victor did how did sue hear and know
what Ben was saying from around the
corner all the way back here synthetics
act as a second skin adapting to your
body's individual needs as it turns out
my body needs to show as much cleavage
as possible movie glosses over the fact
that they conceived of plan for train
for and execute this mission in six
weeks this computer screen contains
equal amounts of character names and
useless information eg a until cosmic
event nine hours
you could have kind of enclosed didn't
you they planned this entire mission in
six weeks but have no better way to put
flour samples out in the path of the
cosmic event than to send out a dude in
a spacesuit I'll say because the storm
hits in less than 30 seconds after you
say this then translates reads panic as
impatient asshole for some reason
probably so he can waste more time out
here and everyone can get superpowers
trying to save him cry spend himself the
lone human space walking outside the
ship should have noticed this from
cosmic event was way closer than it
should be
this bursting get your powers montage is
looking stupidly I swear to you Ben
they've done everything humanly possible
haha character that everyone knows will
be horribly disfigured has to endure a
fake-out disfigurement just for laughs
it's funny but laugh already assholes
the steward achelous lee large chair mu
he rips off the villainous mad at his
board of directors thing from spider-man
sexy nurses so Florence Nightingale in
for Johnny that she doesn't even bother
to tell his temperatures off the charts
if the screen was able to keep track of
his temperature what did she need the
thermometer for and if the screen just
projects the thermometers readings then
why did she look at the thermometer
instead of the screen how you feeling
solid we secretly replaced all your
character development with gut-busting
inside jokes shouldn't
possibly predicted yes he totally could
possibly have predicted that the storm
arrived seven hours earlier than his
calculations simply by looking out a
window once or twice
didn't he say to meet me how did she
know that that meant to go to a place
where a helicopter would take them to
the mountain by the way your temperature
was 209 probably nothing to worry about
I'll see you at the bottom of the hill
this song how did she find him remember
he fell off the cliff and in midair he
turned into the Human Torch and
crash-landed and she also took a tumble
I'm sure this isn't in any way abnormal
this shouldn't concern me at all as a
trained nurse or anyone with common
sense
cameraman forgets to pan up sir I have
always wondered why sue good question no
idea I'm gonna turn into a supervillain
face I can't does anyone say what normal
people would say when they see something
like this so if sue hadn't freaked out
and knocked over the wine bottle win
with the students powers have ever
manifested next week when he sees an old
lady dropping some groceries
he still hasn't put on clothes that
means he was rescued on the mountainside
and flew or rode all the way back to the
lab without so much as considering a new
pair of pants you know it'll be really
interesting if they ever find a way to
put the Fantastic Four and Captain
America in the same movie I get that his
DNA has been fundamentally altered by
the space cloud but how did his cells
add mass
we'll never find him now we've heard
about Ben's beloved Debs about 1,500
times in this film but they don't bother
showing us her until this stupid I'm a
rock now baby see and now I know why
because it's Andrea run because some
girl went running a kind of a road is
this
I guess Ben didn't cause one disturbance
when he walked on the Brooklyn Bridge to
go pout about his wife not loving him
anymore what's the worst that could
happen character mocks a cliche from
earlier cliche haha birds don't know
he's a person just when you think the
movies already drained the cliche well
drawing outcomes coincidental suicide
guy what the hell is this driver
speeding through a wreck for also
suddenly there's a big pileup where that
speeding car just whizzed past with no
problem are you fucking kidding me these
assholes just happen to be on the bridge
right when Ben's little incident is
happening this is a city of nine million
people wait Ben just caused this traffic
jam accidentally a few seconds ago now
that are randomly two cop cars there to
do crowd control
no nobody regards stuff like this with
any amazement whatsoever
how many therapy blood relations do not
supersede the hotness of Jessica Alba
you would totally not need therapy
unless it's therapy about wanting to
bang your sister even though her
invisibility already failed her once on
this bridge and embarrassed her sue
decides forget and just takes off her
bra and panties anyway also invisible
naked Jessica Alba wait a minute wasn't
the reason she became invisible so that
she could get past all these cops so
where Johnny and Ben suddenly able to
just prance past all the cops - also
there are four police cars not two and
an ambulance and two fire engines all
randomly on the bridge together when the
traffic jam started do that because she
got naked and invisible that was 100%
extraneous that's not how fire works
this is from the desolation of smaug
school of fire protection right oh look
more powers being discovered by accident
also why does everyone that was in the
space cloud get one power except for Sue
who gets to change their mind on
arresting someone based on crowd
applause oh come on you know what kind
of bull pens wife when I've had to go
through to make it to this exact spot on
the Brooklyn Bridge to meet up with her
husband also you came all the way here
to tell your now hero husband that you
don't want to be married anymore holy
that's harsh also you see them on the
news you think to yourself I need to run
to the bridge and tell him we're through
right now also Deb's is addictive things
jeez when do people get tired of
clapping for scientists not celebrities
too late huh magic TV just happens to be
around so that the cop could show read
there were already celebrities the
fantastic first of all roll credits
second of all there's no way that the
news would have come up with some
brilliant name for these superheroes
already and the church would have had
fantastic in the title welcome back to
the Baxter dr. Richards Stan Lee cameo
is Stan Lee how come van can't turn it
on and off like we care that's what
we're here to find out this is maybe the
only superhero movie in history where
the entire plot of the movie is the
superheroes trying to get rid of their
badass new abilities hmm I wonder what
kind of things go in this book this
article repeats itself after five
paragraphs and this article is not about
voting and this article is the exact
same as the previous one only they
change nine-year-old to high-school
student
meanwhile cut off article is about the
same thing the vote article was about we
need to understand what happened to your
DNA so let's hit your rock knee with a
hammer
you were at 4,000 Kelvin that's the
temperature of the Sun that kind of heat
should have done a lot more damage hell
it should have melted the titanium
chamber he was in before he even hit
2,000 Kelvin and it should have burned
at the very least this whole apartment
building down is that coming that's a
rude question to ask women hey guys hey
we need to interrupt this relationship
drama one more time because when we keep
coming back to it it gives me a feeling
of euphoria stronger than titanium or
carbon steel harder than diamonds how
did your little med clinic have any of
the equipment necessary to test and
confirm any other you were saying right
now huge shot but there's no way he can
see what he's writing this far away
while uniforms were exposed to the storm
like us so they can transform like us
well that's convenient it prevents
assholes like us asking how do the
uniforms keep up with their superpowers
wired is still selling that Reed
Richards is bankrupt if you we saw at
the beginning of this movie
invisible naked Jessica Alba part two
has been gotten to eat yet he's still
fumbling with forks and trying to pick
up food it's been like months right I'm
gonna build a machine to recreate the
story why do you need to go up to study
the storm in the first place then this
is possible ha ha no she also movie
keeps teasing us with naked Jessica Alba
with no intention of actually showing us
naked Jessica Alba the Fantastic Four
keep their extra rolls of toilet paper
in a room far away from the actual room
you would need it this is a typical New
York Post headline but am I the only one
who thinks John Claude Van Damme should
be here kicking von doom in the head and
the title should be banned damn for Von
Doom no okay moving on how is this the
first time this has happened once he
realizes what his powers are capable of
Victor takes revenge on the board of
directors guy because this movie
literally started out as a photocopy of
the spider-man script what's with these
lights huh about the IPO no hard
feelings right why is this guy nervous
around Mount Doom all the sudden does he
know that he has this kind of power he
obviously doesn't because he starts
mocking him right after this so they've
been locked up in the building and not
going out in public for what I thought
was a few weeks and yet he's still got a
custom license plate for his Porsche
that is based on his superpowers it
takes weeks and weeks just to receive
custom ordered plates nighttime
establishing shot Jon he needs to get
out of here Porsche leaving the garage
with the headlights on and then BAM it's
broad daylight we interrupt this
superhero movie to bring you grease if
he burned the tires why does this
assholes car make an engine sputtering
noise
these guys are not the fucking Beatles
everyone does not love them instantly
and completely because of that one
incident and a few CTV News nickname
they were given that sounds great in
theory ladies until you realize that his
penis is floppy rubber I think that's
funny pebbles oh good the part we've
been waiting to see for a whole hour
the hearings start fighting with each
other scene clearly I can't let product
placement this stupid go by without a
comment but all I can think of right now
is curse make it a triple put it on my
tab and loses his wife but thankfully
there's a superhot blind Kerry
Washington waiting in the wings
you can't down lien that they've been
shut up in that building for enough
weeks for Johnny to get his custom
license plate but not long enough for
Ben to learn how to pick up a glass
without breaking it that's called having
your cake and breaking it - I guess when
this relationship gets serious her
vagina will go blind - ha ha Latveria
also this is what you get for
humanitarian contributions some scary
Halloween masks remember this place of
course this is where I first asked you
out oh no it was not as clearly spelled
out in the memory scrapbook you guys met
at MIT what circumstances would have led
to you coming out to romantic New York
City sites if you weren't already dating
what possible reason could he have for
taking his time the space cloud also
altered his DNA so it'd be more
susceptible to obvious reverse
psychology tactics the following
dialogue is filled with cliches enjoy
why is everyone on my ass if you live
your life I'll live mine sue and
Johnny's conflict literally comes in the
form of an argument about how much the
public truly cares about Johnny he
spelled out power on the inner core
control but apparently did not have
enough room to do it on the outer core
or chamber controls scientists running
out of time and funding test his
theories on himself
oh no Jessica Alba's Brust sir in
trouble Von Doom is the only person in
New York who notices this Leonard bring
Ben Grimm to the Baxter building
because Ben Grimm has been shown to be
the kind of guy who just does whatever
people named Leonard tell him to do
Johnny Storm who's always mugged by fans
goes into an apparently empty Times
Square and it's the only person who
notices that I knew Von Doom had
electrical powers but does he have
superhuman strength - also no he's dead
now didn't the Machine make Reed's
rubber and his horse did he sleep it off
try to figure out how he's not read soup
right now let alone standing confidently
and ready to fight someone are you okay
never better Jimmy
well that was necessary what happens to
rubber when it's supercooled this guy
knows read isn't literally made out of
rubber great he interrupts Fantastic
Four to bring you Eyes Wide Shut shut
your eyes I feel like I've said this
recently apparently Johnny storms flight
failure is just like a propeller going
down at an old biplane two down two to
go
without binoculars or telescope or any
verification do makes a giant leap that
Johnny died in that explosion sue
doesn't put up a force field even when
it's obvious doom is about to strike
Marco Polo that's racist it's time to
end this and do it already
it depends exactly one minute to change
back into the thing take the elevator
all the way down to the Baxter building
run a distance that is probably at least
a half mile if not more get in the
elevator of dooms building and go on the
way to the top and smack through the
perfect wall to stop doom also been
somehow transformed himself back into
the thing because I guess Reed built the
machine with an easy-to-find reverse
switch movie goes out of its way to show
us random dude racing to avoid the flood
but that eliminates him entirely from
the wide shot movie unintentionally
inspires the amazing spider-man to
imbibe and saying something about
villains saying something before they
kill someone has even become tiring
good god Wilhelm get out of the way
there's fight happening in the street
Johnny in ghostbusters it worked it was
their last resort but in this movie they
really need Johnny to reach the
temperatures of the Sun oh no dude she
could barely contain one electricity
blast from Doom ten seconds ago remember
we had to throw the mailbox of Doom to
save her but whatever I guess I just
want this dead Fantastic Four steals the
nosebleed when using super powers thing
from Chronicle oh wait these assholes
wrap it cool the hot metal bad guy but
don't punch him into a million brittle
pieces for some reason yeah with
miraculous Kerry Washington love
anything is possible
so you locked him in a shipping
container at least they put parallax
deep into the ground you guys already
been trying also were you just locking
it up and signing off on the cargo well
already out to sea also like a stop men
are working on this right now who top
men
always be back to that weird start fresh
[Music]
full cast for tomorrow a few sprinkles
of genius for the chance of doom
[Music]
Wow totally bailed he's always right
good thing it doesn't always know what
he's got
[Music]
Mirror Mirror
to obtain a special dialing wand please
mash the keypad with your palm our
uniforms are exposed to the storm like
us so they can transform like this your
sword can stretch as far as you can
without injuring yourself
I'm machine washable tiling that's a new
feature what did you do please think
motherfucker looks just like the thing
so tell me what happens when you
superheat rubber the same thing that
happens to everything else the power of
the Sun
in the palm of my hand